all right sensation yes sensation where
are you from originally where' you grow
up Texas what part Houston
Houston what was your family like
growing
up um I'm not going to lie I only spent
like 10 years around my
family um I left around the age of like
11 to 12 years old never returned then
since then been on my own where' you go
um so at first I got taken into the
system and then I ate W from the system
which I ran away from
placement um I was gone for about 5
years um I kind of like made myself like
known to my family that I was still
around um a lot of my family didn't know
if something happened to me or you know
if I was just ducked off but that was
the case you know I was just ducked off
um I have a lot of Prior history in my
family that I dislike so with that being
said that it's just like what kind of
stuff was going on that you ended up in
theer system
so once okay so basically from the
beginning when I was like young as [__]
uh me and M used to go through it um
along with my siblings and um it was
just never like it was like sensation
was always a mistake you know what I'm
trying to say so um that's why I'm the
person I am today because I'm strong I
was built like that I've always been
belittle um I've always been put down
I've always been abused I've always been
through [__] that I feel like I never
deserved you know what I'm trying to say
physical mentally wise um just just
everything you know what I'm trying to
say um it got to a point that I was
crying every day I really didn't have a
childhood so I don't even know what it
feels to have a childhood to really be
honest with you because I always had to
strive for myself I always had to be
self advocated I never had that support
from my parents or I never had that
support from my dad I rarely know who my
dad is the DNA test did you feel loved
as a kid not at
all and you went to the Foster system
how was that experience for you uh like
I said I really didn't even get to
experience it that much because I left
because I was discom I was uncomfortable
it was a discomfort for me and there
also um being around strangers being
around people I don't know being placed
in different homes getting interviews
with different foster parents going to
different group homes with different
staffs staff not having good good
intentions towards me good intention
towards other kids it's just not a good
look you know what I'm trying to say um
I never wanted to surround myself with
that um and it's like if I've been
through that as a child and I'm trying
to better myself and I'm placing myself
in a worst situation although foster
care is supposed to be a better
situation foster care is not a better
situation for nobody at all and it's
best to be home with your parents but if
your parents doing you a certain type of
way then it's just best for you to be
independent and that's what I learned in
life because it's just like what else so
whether with your family or in the
Foster system was there any abuse um yes
with my family there was much abuse um
with my like Foster system type of
life I kind of like met a lot of girls
met a lot of staff I bonded with a lot
of people but it happened all in the
withd of two weeks and then I left never
came back
um never wanted to come back um I ended
up having to start dealing with grown
men um I end up having to start having a
better mindset than what I was so that I
wouldn't just be feel me raped dead
killed out here um because I was dealing
with older people at a very very very
young age just to make just to make it
to where I had to make it to just to
survive on a day-to-day basis and I just
feel like it was hard for me but you're
saying sexually
um something like that yeah
yeah and you went to the streets at what
age around 12 really 10 going on 11 but
officially I was like not talking to
nobody or not really asking for no help
at the age of 12 girl a girl that young
in the out in the streets gets into
trouble for
sure so what where did that start like
what kind of trouble are you getting
into um trouble wise I'm not going to
lie I really didn't like I'm not really
like a hothead I don't just go around
I'm not a crash dummy I don't just do
anything with life um on my free time um
since I was so young don't get me wrong
I still used to go to libraries I still
used to you feel me still feel like I
wanted to live that kid life all those I
knew at the end of the night where was I
going to go sleep where was I going to
go lay my head where was I going to go
eat that night who was going to make
sure that I was good or am I going to
make sure I'm good and it was always I
had to make sure I was good so that
being said
it was just like don't get me wrong I
never really got myself into trouble
like as in jail record wise I don't have
a record like I I mean I've did [__] but
I really ain't never got caught for the
[__] that I've did so with that being
said it's like I really don't have a
record behind me so like I can go get a
job right now and I'll be I'll be able
to do it but it's just like you know is
it or not never got in trou you got
introduced to prostitution at what age
um I got introduced to prostitution
around the age of 16 years old
um I kind of introduced myself to
prostitution um I kind of seen like what
my friends and my surroundings was
doing um it took me a minute because at
first when I used to like when I used to
see 304s I used to be like I'll never be
that I'll never be that person I'll
never be outside I'll never like that
you in the cold no I never see myself
outside like that so even even now like
I be looking at girls when I don't be
outside be like damn how do I do it like
but it's just like I kind of introduced
myself to it so I kind of like made
myself used to the routine and I have my
own self routine until I start learning
like it's certain [__] behind this so
it's just like okay let me not be a
renegade for too long let me get a
little bit of management so that I can
manage myself and they can help me
manage myself so that I can have better
guidance but it's just like everything
ain't pizza and cream with that
situation either you know what I'm
trying to say so as I went along and I
went along and I went along it was like
it was cool it was okay but then as you
get to knowing you might go with this
pimp like my first my first turnout
folks they were wonderful you know they
treated me right I always like had
everything I wanted um I always gave him
everything he wanted it was always
Mutual feeling it was just that things
started happening I start getting my
emotions involved and I feel like in
this game this is not for emotions to
get involved so I had to like disconnect
myself from that situation before it
became something it wasn't supposed to
be because this is really all about
business there's a there's a wide
range of types of pimps aren't there yes
very much so from the worst you can
imagine to that are surprisingly
surprisingly died by surprise like damn
for real
is that true yeah good good guys for
sure but it's like I've dealt with
another pimp like you know
and he got lives double lives baby mamas
like everything like but mind you I was
bringing like you know I was making
money making money for him and he was
wondering why I was falling off and why
I wasn't do what I was supposed to do no
more and then he start tripping on me
like all all due to to the fact that I
find out that you have a wife but if my
feet belong on the pavement you have no
business laying up in the bed with the
next female because I'm a prostitute for
a reason you invest in me and I invest
in you but in other words you felt like
I'm supposed to invest in you your
family your kids and then you don't
invest in me I didn't like that so now
at this current moment it's just like
I'm kind of on my own you know again
because I came back to realization that
reneging is just the answer everything
that a [__] could do for me I could do
for myself everything that I could do
for a [__] he could do for herself and
if a [__] can't do it for herself that
mean that you don't have no emotion so
it's just like honestly feel like I
might as well just be a prostitute you
know live my life and be with who I want
to be with but just not have a pimp you
know what I'm trying to say why why can
you explain why so many young women are
with
pimps um in this game I honestly feel
like a lot of these females want to be
with pimps
because [__] want dick I'm sorry to
say like that [__] want just ju just
love I feel like honestly that's how I
look at it because I don't feel like sex
is like it's not a turn on for me
because at the end of the day it's my
occupation every day every day I wake up
I'm like okay I'm going to go outside
and make some money so if if I sell
[__] for a living I don't want to go
lay up with a [__] and [__] you for
free what am I [__] you for free for
you know what I'm trying to say so it's
like I feel like a lot of these [__]
feel like okay if I go out and make this
[__] money I'm going to go go get
[__] no that's not the case because
the way I look at it is I'm going to go
outside I'm going to make some money and
I'm going to get [__] by these tricks
and then I'm going to have what I want
to have but you laying up with a [__]
and this is what a lot of [__] do
they want to lay up with a [__] they
want to go down when they want to go
down they want to come in with a bare
minimum amount and then it's just like
[__] want to do better just to make
it happen for a [__] and it's just like
that [__] don't even want to make it
happen for them if you know what I'm
trying to say and it's like at the end
of the day I feel like it's a million a
million penises out here you know what
I'm trying to say so for a female to be
stuck on that one male and for that
female to want to pay that one male
continuously and you're having problems
and you're having conflict and it's like
nothing's going right for you it's just
like it don't make sense because a lot
of these girls I see on a day-to-day
basis it's like damn my daddy keeping me
outside damn my daddy doing this damn my
daddy doing that I never can go outside
and hear somebody say oh yeah I'm having
a good day my daddy did this my daddy
did that I can never go like to up to a
prostitute and just hear nothing but
good like just good energy I hear
something negative and everything so
it's like I don't feel like I don't feel
like prostitutes even need pimps I don't
feel like I don't feel like they should
want to deal with them but I feel like
the reason they want to deal with them
is through sex but that is our
occupation so I don't see compion right
that you can respect somewhat cuz he's
not being taken advantage of like all
the tricks are exactly because you you
don't do that to her you can't respect a
trick my point and you're being treated
like a trick because what what are you
doing for her she's giving you some
[__] and you're giving her outfits and
heels
and why [__] a female that's paying you
and you don't know if she's really down
for for you A lot of people you get you
get they get a female in the next 3 4
hours oh yeah her [__] was tight her
[__] was good ain't you supposed to be
some pimping you know what I'm trying to
say like a lot of pimps popping about
how they artist and how they all that
and how they follow the rules and it's
really rules just like it's rules in
this world it's really rules in reality
of this game and it's like I feel like a
lot a lot of this new generation pimping
is not like old school pimping I feel
like old school pimping is a little bit
better than that you know new school
because this new school they changed it
yes they want to they want to just it's
like okay you know I don't know if you
know when a person say it's more to a
whole life but I feel like I'm more than
a ho I feel like I deserve a life too I
feel like I don't just want to see the
blade 24 hours out the day I feel like
oh let me go to the beach oh I feel like
let me go to the movies let me do this
let me do that let me go out a lot of
these girls never see the beach they
never see bever they never see anything
I'm going to go I'm go do what the [__]
I want to do because I'm not the blade
24/7 I might as well sit in the room and
watch the
walls what like what am I going to sit
outside for and then like I said figuroa
is a Dry Blade figuroa like I tell a lot
of these females if your pimp has you on
fig he wants nothing but Chum chains I
don't care what nobody say a ban a night
is not nothing you going to spin about a
ban in two hours that's a room you
outfit your [__] outfit some gas and
some food that's it unless you getting
cheap [__] and a lot of you [__] like
pills you [__] like weed you [__] is
addicted to this you [__] is addicted
to that so that whole band is gone so
you being on fig is Chum change so it's
like about a 100 prostitutes over 100
prostitutes on fig about every day F
fighting over a small amount of money
thank you we fighting we on this corner
that corner then this pimp tripping cuzz
this [__] on that corner he don't want
her on that corner he don't want her
playing over here like we can't never
make our money and comfort we always
have something as a burden on our
shoulders from some type of person that
we used to deal with or just from
somebody that don't want us in their
jurisdiction and I feel like you know it
is what it is but at the end of the day
it's always out of town it's always a
different blade like fig is not just
answer so all this fig like you know
activity is just and meanwhile there's
girls who are on only
fans with or without pimps making very
much money making 400 times what you yes
making very much more money than what we
make on a day-to-day basis M just off
content which makes no sense yeah they
don't have to touch it which a lot of us
can do that but guess what a lot of us
don't have that mindset they not smart
enough like I said I mean I've played
the net I've had I had a mindset but I
don't have the patience for only fans
I'm not going to lie a lot of work yes I
do not have the patience it's all a lot
of work but at least some of it is a lot
of money right not that sex work is
something any female should be doing
right for sure
ideally you find another path but when
you don't have when you don't grow up
with those role models and options then
you end up in the streets for
sure you're you're how old now 20
20 no
kids you have two kids kids and where
are they they with their
daddy do you see
them uh
periodically um you
know I don't really honestly this is my
fear I have two girls you know so I
never in life for my girls to turn to a
prostitute so while I'm living this life
I want to see them periodically I don't
really want to see them too much cuz
like I said
I'm living a lifestyle I'll never want
my kids to live so when I'm done and I
get to where I want to be I'm going go
back for my kids but I know that they in
a good hands with their daddy so don't
waste too much time
though kids need their mom of course and
I understand that
but until I feel like I want I want to
be able to show my kids that I have
something for them I've showed them
multiple things they've had the life
they wanted before but I don't feel like
they have everything they want and I
feel like this another reason that
brought me to this game because a 95
I've had it multiple times you tried it
three four times a 9 to5 I make what I
make in two weeks in a day so for me to
want to sit up here and stand and deal
with customers that's cussing me out
every [__] day I rather deal
with a trick that I could walk away from
or that I could pepper spray or stab and
get the [__] away from then deal with
customers every day and getting paid $14
$15 $16 an hour and then it's adding up
to
13,500 every two weeks or 13 or not even
1,300 and then if you get paid bi-weekly
about
$1,200 I make that in a day so imagine
two two three days 1,200 time 3 I can
make that like you know that's just
double the amount I understand it's not
the best occupation but at the end of
the day it is what it is because what
else you know what I'm trying to
say it's a tough
situation because in order for you to
get $34 an hour or or up more like that
you need trade you need either a trade
under your belt you need like um certain
jobs aren't like accepting geds anymore
you need your actual high school diploma
yeah this is why education is so
important yes how far how far did you go
to
school so to be honest with you
when I was in foster care I got checked
into school I kept checking myself into
school when I ran away so in total when
I checked my transcripts like about two
years ago I had been to 17 schools in
less than one school year so with that
being said I ended up dropping out at
the grade of e e8th grade I dropped out
eighth grade never been back to school
since um I did like online
courses um I did this CNA little trade
class or whatever the case may have been
and that's all I really did but I have
not been I did not go to high school I
did not that's what I'm saying I really
did not see what a childhood was I
didn't get to have prom I didn't get to
do none of that all that I did not get
to do like school dances I didn't get to
do all that I didn't get to
do so I know you're were just a teenager
yesterday but do you have any regrets do
do you have any things you wish you had
done differently in your
life um I really don't say I regret
anything I regret the family I was put
in that's that's what I regret yeah I
feel like if I was put in a different if
I was put around a different support
system a different support team that
would changed everything um I think I'll
be a very very good person I think I'll
be on track
like I've played in movies before I I've
I've did multiple things like you know I
have a lot of things that I've
experienced in life I've traveled the
world like but it's
just and drugs no I do marijuana I might
get a little drunk laugh a lot but I'm
not doing no hard drugs I'm not doing
none of that I don't even pop pills I
will stay outside all night on an energy
drink and Hennessy shot I can't do no
not no ills not no perks can't do it's
cold out there right now what that mean
alcohol I'm not taking no pills I feel
like the first time I ever took a pill I
feel like my ass cannot rise off but
you're out there wearing next to nothing
it's in the 40s it's okay windy too it's
okay I'm just going to have to deal with
the wi might as well go to the beach to
get used to it I'm not- I'm not popping
no pills and you're working every day
yes you think I'm I'm not popping no
pills I'll be outside with my eyes low
before I go outside and be like Oh I'm
going to pop this pill and be up for 2
three days drinking orange juice and not
having no appetite that's good to have
that discipline when I want to sleep I
want to sleep ain't no pill going to
keep me up that's not me so I'm not
going to feel like I can't do something
I want like I want to be able to control
my own body with that I cannot control
my own body so it will not work at all
good for
you what would you like to be doing in
five years or in two years um in 2 years
this is what I really want to do I
really want to move to Texas I want to
have my own land um I want to get my
kids are you saving money in 2 years are
you saving money right now actually yes
I am like I have a bank account um I at
least put up something every week I was
trying to put up something like every
day but it was like how do all these
girls that are making $1,200 $1,500
2,000 a day a night not save money so
let me tell you something so a whole
outfit is about $60 $70 you get to use
some
heels that's about the same amount or
probably about 100 110 okay then you got
to pay for a room right and then you got
to support your daily habits right and
then on top of supporting your daily
habits you got to make sure that you
have a quota right so if you're not
reneging you not if you're not reneging
you can't save if you're reneging you
have all rights but to save
but even when you reneging you still got
to make sure you straight you you you've
wacked up about $500 with with your
expenses that you just name uh probably
more than that but you it depends on
like the time frame you a new outfit
every day yeah a new outfit every day
every day every day every day of the
year yes
fishnet like okay me I'll get a fishnet
and they rip sometimes so I'll go give
me another one but sometimes I'll give
me outfit that I could wash and rewear
but not the same day but like a month
two later you know but other than that
I'll give me outfit every day I'm not
going to go outside and the same thing
you're lucky you're buying $60 outfits
even when what do you call that when I
have my I'll be wearing wigs you know so
when I used to have my wigs or if I have
my wig right now I'll have a different
color in the next 2 three days I'm not
going to keep the same wig going and
that [__] just be wigs heels
outfits yes weed wigs HS outfits weed
rooms um some rooms charge you extra now
for visitors you know so [__] so you're
you're up to7 800 about that so now what
do you have left to save okay so then
you put about $200 up which is
reasonable and then you have $200 left
for yourself which you don't want to be
outside with no money if you renting so
if you have folks you ain't going to
have no money outside you probably got
about $5 $10 and they going to be cost
them whole doll so it's just like hey
the other $200 but do you have a car
yeah I have a car you have a car so
there's car there's expensive that gas
and insurance and mhm and imagine i' be
going to gas
stations and imagine traveling from
Pomona to this blade to that blade to
San Diego to this to that and you still
got to get your car fixed you still got
to make sure you got oil you still got
to make sure this that and then some gas
don't do [__] so you got to make sure
you go to the right gas station it's
just a whole bunch of stuff that you got
to worry about close to a th now there's
all your money
there so then guess what back outside
again if you have a [__] you can always
make it work you're on you're on a
hamster wheel yes it's goes keep going
keep going keep going just like a tumble
weat in win you need a sugar daddy H I
have multiple but you know I kind of
like moved so sugar daddy with money is
what you need yes real money I need a
sugar daddy that's going to pay me every
day
every day not a payment every week
allowance every week I need a payment
every day to handle my daily expenses
how much you need every day from a sugar
dating guys can reply in the comments I
really want about
like I think I'd be straight if he gave
me like three Bands A Day 3,000 a day
3,000 a day I'll be straight every day
of the year I'm not greedy it's a
million a year you need a million a year
well
hey what are you a sugar daddy
for prostitution is starting to sound
like a good good idea for guys [__] a
man could do the same thing no but I'm
just saying a guy can go get a girl on
fig for 100 bucks and have some fun and
he's done a guy can go get a girl on fig
not I don't think you come get me on
fake for 100 bucks whatever 200 300 you
know it depend you you know just not to
[__] but you
know it's a lot of bear backers it's a
lot of that out here so yeah it's a lot
of that going on and that's why I don't
really I I refuse that's why fig is just
not it you got $80 $60 [__] out here
you got $40 [__] out here and that's
why the [__] that the cost of living
is the problem for everybody yes the
cost of living and the cost of gas the
cost of running on what do you call
that running running on gas I mean today
when I drove here I swear I was at 82
miles now I'm at 32
miles left in your car yes so now when I
leave here I got to go to the gas
station yeah you're something some
that's not you didn't drive 50 miles to
get
here no I was about 43 minutes
away
H what does this lifestyle do to you
emotionally it's it's a struggle
emotionally you probably feel like
you're never getting ahead
right this lifestyle kind of like
stresses me out a little bit but
sometimes it could be a happy moment um
the worst thing that ever happened to me
on fig girl is I got in a Mel's car and
when I got in that Mel's car all I seen
no all I felt and heard was somebody
tumbling from the back seat end up being
two
Mexicans um
the one in the front seat and up
grabbing a AK-47 off the side of the
driver's seat and holding me on gunpoint
and telling me that basically in order
for me to return back to where I want to
return back to I need to call my pimp
and I need to tell him that this is how
much they need and he has to give it to
them and meet them at the nearest
7-Eleven and they'll release me to
him my folks tell
them oh okay okay well cut that [__]
finger off and call me when you do
it okay so they like cried to his so
they put the phone on mute they're like
cry to him make it seem like you're
serious mind you these Mexicans are
telling me that they're part of the
cartel but you're speaking
English Okay flag number one now the
only reason I'm scared is because y'all
have this gun one of y'all have a knife
and the other one just sitting there
just like [__] don't move okay so they
call him back and they're telling him
like we're F to take your girl to Tiana
and they're trying to translate the
Spanish to him through the phone so that
he could hear what the [__] going on
and he like okay well do whatever y'all
going to do kill the [__] and then you
know just call me after y'all do it send
me a picture after y'all do
it I'm looking in my head like okay so
it just threw me off so
then they ended up taking me all the way
to Englewood and I'm telling them like
he's not going to believe nothing y'all
saying like I don't care if y'all tell
him that y'all going to shoot shoot me
in my hair right now he not care what
the [__] y'all got to say so I don't
know what goofy gang [__] y'all got
going on but it's not going to work like
that more the story they dropped me off
of Englewood I end up making my way back
to Fig and they didn't rob you yes they
took my wig off they took my phone they
took like the Trap that I had and and
then what happened oh and then they let
me out and when they did let me out they
have the gun to me and they said [__]
Don't Do No weird [__] and yeah after
that I made my way back to Fig and the
most tra no the most traumatizing
situation was I was dealing with my
folks
and he did not believe that happened he
going to say I got in the car and I made
it happen on purpose so in my head I'm
like laughing because how the [__] can I
control with a trick I do but now it
it's like so funny to me because it's
like damn I really could have been dead
but I I once again I was striving for
myself how does this make you feel
you're it was just like you're alone I'm
I'm all alone regardless like it don't
matter who say they [__] with you who
say they got your back who no it's
nobody here for you so it's just like
I'm just like I don't even know what to
say to him but it's crazy cuz I still
stay with him after you did yes what the
matter with
you I'm I'm a very very big strong
believer and giv multiple chances and I
feel like after that yes I I gave I gave
that person a chance after after they
had I found out they had a wife on me
and that I basically I basically was
just giving money and being outside for
for nothing not for me at least at least
I was under impression you know so I
really don't know what to say about that
one because I could I could manage about
six of you girls and make make everybody
money if I don't have time for it and
you see that's why I'm like you guys
make some crazy decisions yes and not
that's what I'm saying I canot admit in
this lifestyle I made some [__] up
decisions that I will regret does that
come from not having a dad I really
honestly think that it really does
because why if I had a man a male figure
in my life coming up but I really wasn't
around that long so don't know how that
played out a dad who knows the
difference between [__] and
something real right is going to teach
that to his daughter just by being
around him exactly so I feel like if I
had a male figure that I would have
known like okay this type of male figure
that I'm looking for cuz usually a lot I
hear a lot of [__] say they want
somebody just like their daddy you get
somebody like your daddy then is a
person I love you a person that's going
to protect you and [__] like that not
like as in a different way but like you
know in that type of way so it's just
like a lot of girls out here I feel like
we make decisions and we just move off
our first instinct and don't think
before we do I feel like we just be like
oh yeah that [__] got this that got
that oh he got that forign whip right
there oh yeah and his [__] fly like
you feel me I feel like we jump off
looks I feel like we jump off what we
see we don't jump off oh this is the
actual situation like people don't think
Inside the Box people think people think
people think Inside the Box not outside
the box and I'm the type of person I've
been through so much now that I got to
start thinking outside the box because
I'm going to trap myself inside that box
once I start not thinking outside the
box despite your limited education you
seem like a very smart girl thank you
like somebody who can figure
out what's [__] and what isn't for
sure I seen [__] from a mile
away I just think you need to figure out
another hustle yes and
honestly I'm not going to lie so when I
came into this New Year's this year I
was supposed to be retired right at 20
yes
but it worked for 3 weeks
right and um I was slowing down I was
slowing down and something was like yeah
[__] you not done [__] and I just got
back outside you needed money or what
but honestly was crazy cuz that day I
had money I had I had what I needed it
wasn't like oh I needed this I needed
that oh I'm struggling I had what I need
it I was just like what am I doing like
no this is not you like you know and I
end up going back outside I was cold I
was shivering I was like well let's
let's look at that for a second what is
it that dragg you
back what is it that brought me
back I just was like I just I can't I
can't stop the money you're once that
money gone you're addicted to the fast
money I'm going yes once that money gone
I'm going to need some more money you're
addicted to the fast money yes money go
for me like I like I go through money
how I go through underwear I go through
money how I how I change tampons on my
period so see that that's a problem you
got to work on now yes I have to learn
how to budget there's a lot of flaws but
I can vary so much Adit to my flaws and
why because everything that I feel like
I need to work on I very very much so
try to put an effort into making myself
a better person so a lot of [__] like
even like with people I deal with I'll
I'll snitch on myself I'mma tell you
what I'm doing wrong before you know a
[__] be like oh she's doing this
wrong no I'm going to tell you what I'm
doing wrong I'mma tell you what I feel I
need to improve I'm not just going to be
like oh yeah [__] that no I've
interviewed so many girls that do this
kind of
work I've only met maybe one or two that
know how to handle money maybe three
righteous and and and that sounds about
right it does whereas there's thousands
or definitely close to a thousand that
I've interviewed that that do not know
how to handle money for sure and that's
why the pimp comes in he'll hand you the
money for it I mean whether you can
trust him and some of them don't even
know how to handle it they don't even
know yes so that management ain't even a
management cuz a management is when he's
tell you stuff but it's under a
guideline and it's going okay this
what's going to happen this was going to
happen and you got some show for it and
half of them they just want to buy cars
crash it by lean we perks and smoke away
and just sit in their [__]
driver's seat turn on that [__]
heater and pick up a [__] and collect
trap and keep it pushing that's all
these pimp want to do nowadays they
don't want to take time invest into the
[__] learn the [__] to build the [__]
the way they want to build the [__] to
break on the [__] the way they want to
break on a [__] other than that it's
just like they just want to sit there
collect trap and be warm while they
[__] is cold and then you come in you
be ice [__] cold why they just
looking at you just damn you okay you
cold yes the [__] I am
that's why the [__] you out this heater
on you know so it's just like I'm used
to that that's why I'm slowing down on
dealing with people now because they
don't know how to manage that [__]
either so if they don't know how to
manage it I might as well manage it my
goddamn self cuz I'm either know how or
not know how just like they is they
either not going to know how or they
going to know how and you going to run
into very few of them that know how
because next thing you know that car be
crashing 2 days and then they be wanting
to [__] to tra for another car not off
now that you've already connected
multiple times probably hundreds
thousands of times Sex and Money MH is
it going to be even possible for you not
to be a sex worker of some
sort uh no it's not it's not hard I
could really like if I want to quit
today I could like really really quit
it's just fast money I probably wouldn't
I probably would do it but I'll just Rob
tricks I wouldn't even no but if if you
met a a square guy that had his heart
and head in the right place mhm seem to
care about you would I turn him out to
the game no no would you would you
square up a little bit would I square up
no I'm not Square enough for No Square
for what what I'm going to square for a
square for for for a life that might
lead you to being a mother of your kids
and no saving for the future I'll never
I'll would never want a square I can't
even deal with a square I'll slap a
square I'm a very toxic toxic female I'm
not going to lie um I love I love all my
relationships like I'm not going to lie
to you I have every [__] that I've ever
talked to tatted on my
body who's Lamar
so we not to talk about that okay how
many guys do you have tattooed on your
on your body um I
have eight names you have eight guys
names tattooed on your body at 20 years
old
Yes W and exactly what I told everybody
on my body if if I die before y'all die
I want everybody on my body to smoke a
wood together regardless if you enemies
or not enemies because I always want
everybody to get along and I want y'all
to drink together and whatever happens
when y'all leave happens when y'all
leave but while yall here I want nothing
but peace that's all I ask
for and I would never get none of these
names covered up why they always mean
something to me I'm only getting one
name covered up because it was a mistake
and I really do regret it and I just
think the way you grow up and the way
people
from a wealthier community perhaps is
the way to say it grows up is is so
drastically
different drastically different for sure
so for people to watch these videos and
say oh you just need to stop working the
streets girl and get a job they have
they have no understanding yeah it's
like it's just like once they get a job
and they get a raise they going in to
stay
when we be
outside we might get something one day
and get two times more that amount the
next day so it's just like it it it is
an addiction you know so it can become
an addiction that you know you can put a
stop on or it could become an addiction
as you know it's like um yeah I'm just
going to keep Hing you know but honestly
it's really it's really easy to stop
it's just all about what motion you have
outside hor but if you were going to
stop doing this what would you do I do
hair I know how to do waxes I know how
to do nails I know how to do a lot of
things um I can also go do like my
outcastes I have a lot of interviews
that people been calling me for for
movies um I'm already in like two or
three movies already um I mean I have
more other things to do than this um I
could work out my auntie's daycare it's
a lot of other things that I can do it's
just like that's not what I choose to do
right
now you're an interesting girl I know a
lot of people say that you have a lot of
potential I appreciate it and you have a
lot of obstacles too yes I do and I need
to figure out which ones are the right
ones that's going to guide me where I
want to
be at 20 years old what would you say is
the most important lesson you have
learned in your
life um the most most important lesson I
learned in my life
is oh don't say don't I don't trust
anybody oh that that's number one that
that that that's that's mandatory that's
not even a lesson yeah that a four years
old
really I honestly life lesson I'm going
to say the lesson I learned in this game
is never think everything is sweet I've
always
since I first got in this game when I
first got in this game I never I never
had instruction so I put myself down so
I figured everything out on my own so it
was
like it was just like I don't know I
don't even know how to say it it was
just like I put myself down so now I'm
kind of like it's just like it's just
that it's just that it's just that it's
just that yeah it's really just that
like I'm just I just learned that it's
just me like it's really just me in this
game me paying a [__] is just it's it's
stupid it's just like I'm just giving my
money to to the ATM I'm giving my money
for somebody could spend it that's
really my biggest lesson that I learned
in this game giving a [__] money is no
good it's really no good I don't care
what he does for you cuz you could do
the exact same thing for yourself so
it's just like it's just that like if
you feel like Pam [__] is so
interesting then he but me I don't feel
like that's interesting no more at first
I did I'm like yeah like let me invest
like let me see a [__] really win but a
[__] don't want to see you win as much
as you want to see him win as much as we
like yeah I [__] with you I [__] with
you I want to see you win they don't
want to see us win like that they just
want to see us make that money and they
want to see them oh here you go put it
in my hand and it's not going to work
like that so my biggest lesson in this
game is don't get give no [__] money
because they all don't deserve our
time that's just the mor of the story
there you go sensation thank you so much
for enlightening us all you're welcome
you're you're a smart girl I appreciate
it I hope you figure out a different
hustle I am I am just give me like give
me about a year give me about a year
about a year no drugs no pimp no drugs
two kids though yeah that was slow you
down a
bit a little bit but it's okay it's
always it's always the obstacle I get on
your way it's either you going to work
with it or you going to fall through it
I'm work with it and I'm going to work
around it and I'm going to make it
through it I'm never going to fall
through it all right okay thanks J
you're
welcome